hello hello hello everyone welcome
to another video on code tekken
tutorials today i'm going to be talking
about this game engine i'm building
ancient archer
and the changes i've made since the last
build
so now we're on build four and uh
yeah just gonna go over the changes
obviously this isn't production ready or
anything like that
and this uh this is like my own
personal project i only talk about it on
the channel because it's
code and i know about it and it's
something that people can learn from
but as far as uh who owns it and all
that it's like
my personal project so i want to start
talking more about
libraries and stuff like this on the
channel and this is just
a great jumping off point for me so
we're going to talk about the main
changes i'm going to walk through some
of the code show you some of the stuff
and we'll kind of go from there and you
guys can take what you want from it and
yeah let's just get into it all right so
build four i mainly focused on
basically trying to make this a more
proper static library
because i noticed something as i was
like
building this on other computers and
then exporting the library
and like starting new projects with this
library because that's basically what
it's intended to be
so basically just like any other c plus
plus library you're supposed to build a
library and then link your real project
to it and use the library to support all
the stuff you're doing
so that's still the intention of this
there's a lot of other libraries like
this i've talked about them a little bit
there's like
ear licked and what else i don't know
there's a few others but
this is this is kind of a common thing
for people to do and that's
you know i'm just doing it mostly for
practice and because i actually want to
make a game with it
and basically i'm too lazy to learn
other people's tools no
that's not entirely true but i just feel
like there's a lot to learn by building
your own tools
even if it's already been done so that's
kind of the point all right main changes
the core is now private and
that doesn't really mean anything in
itself but basically
i factored out a lot of the things that
were in
the public header files that weren't
really supposed to be public
and i put them in this core and this
core is like completely private
there's there's nothing the end user of
the library can do
to like change any of this core stuff
permanently so
that might not be the best way of
wording it but basically it's like
the core functionality of this whole
engine
that shouldn't be messed with only you
know you can toggle stuff on and off and
stuff like that but
yeah it's all in core so all that
private stuff that's like the back end
support of the engine
got factored out
and yeah i guess the main reason for
that also
is several main reasons the public
header files like the ancient archer.h
and ancient archer.cpp they were getting
huge and everything in the cpp
was supposed to be private anyway but i
had like a bunch of stuff that
didn't have public access functions
so i just put that in the core and it's
it's a little weird still i'm still
working on some
kinks but it seems a lot better it's a
lot easier to reason about
because as this grows it becomes more
and more complicated to reason about
and i'm often just changing things to
try to simplify
using in the future all right fix some
texturing support
so there were some issues with alpha and
non-alpha textures
and i added a few upload functions
that now will actually properly use
alpha or not
alpha as you prefer so
before i think i was missing one of them
and
um i forget but
i i basically fixed that up and add a
few things that were missing
internal shaders this is something i've
gone back and forth on
and i'll talk about a little bit but
basically
the whole reason for making putting the
shaders in a dot h
file and they're just now like const
strings
all right where do i start with this
shaders are complicated there's a lot of
different ways to handle them
there's a lot of new technologies coming
out that are supposed to help you handle
them
but i'm just trying to keep it really
simple i don't want to like go down one
road
and then have to backtrack because i've
already done that quite a few times with
these shaders
i was putting them in their own separate
just like text files
and then pathing to them but that became
a problem when i was building the
library
and linking it with other projects
because now what i would also have to do
what was i would have to like grab all
those shader files
and put them with my project as well and
then make sure the path was right so i'd
have to use like the same folders
i used it just was not intuitive at all
like anyone would get stuck
trying to figure out what the heck is
going on with these shaders but if i
just put them all internal
then i can just have the library build
them on the fly
also for your graphics card because
depending on what graphics card and
driver you have
it's going to build the binaries
differently potentially
so i can't necessarily just ship
binaries because a lot of things people
do is there you can actually
save the programs that are built
like your graphics shader program you
can save those
and reuse them without having to rebuild
them every time your program runs
and that's a decent solution but the
problem then becomes
what if your computer doesn't support
these pre-built shaders
you need to rebuild them anyway so
they're being rebuilt
anytime you run the thing which isn't a
huge deal they're pretty small shaders
and this also allows me to in the future
try to do some dynamic stuff depending
on what features you're using so it's
not necessarily going to build ones that
you're not using
and stuff like that so i could get more
into shaders later but i'll probably
do that in my opengl series
but for now yeah the whole basic point
is
they are now just automatic and you
don't really have to think about them
even if you
build this library and link it to
another project it's just going to find
shaders and you just want to think about
it whatever features you use
they will just work i still have to add
in like the pbr
support stuff that's only partially done
still don't have like
shadows but i plan on getting to that at
some point
uh it's just so much other stuff and
actually
the reorganization of this project has
been
necessary because as i kind of expand
things and
and make it a little more consistent i
start to realize that
sometimes i've done things in a way that
are not scalable
or really hard to expand on so it kind
of just requires a refactor before i can
even do what i
intend so that seems to be happening a
lot but
so that's kind of the point of a lot of
these refactors there's like always
refactors and
i i personally don't like refactoring
but it's really necessary when you've
when you've got things that you want to
expand and they it just won't work in
the way you've done it
so it's it's just the nature of uh
programming especially especially when
you're new to this
like this is the first game engine i've
ever worked on and built
so i'm learning as i go a lot of times
sometimes i'll just add a feature and
not realize
that it's uh it's going to be a problem
in the future
and then i'll have to refactor it so
it's just but
it seems like i can definitely tell
as i work on this more and more and like
make mistakes
definitely learning from these mistakes
and realizing okay so next time i add a
feature
in a similar manner do it this better
way
and so it's it's pretty cool it's it's
one of the reasons i love doing this
this is just always something to learn
something to take away that could be
used on
any future project about organizing and
stuff
all right so let's continue i re-added
full screen toggle support that's
actually
like in the core but it's also in the
public header uh not a huge deal
basically i had this in like a long time
ago
and i kept noticing bugs and glitches
with it
but i reread through all the glsw
documentation and i re-added it and it
seems to work
fine now it could maybe be improved a
tiny bit but it's
it's good enough to not really have to
worry about it just works
and i added a call face option this is
just an opengl thing
i just had it off and via the library
there was no way to toggle it on and off
before so now there's a way to toggle it
on and off because
well i kind of noticed this once i
started adding some basic textures which
we'll get to in a second i started
adding like
like all the basic geometry for blocking
out
levels and stuff like that and as i was
doing that i noticed that like you could
see
the plane from both sides but in like
blender or on rio or unity if you add a
plane
you'll notice that you can only see it
from one side and that's because the
back side is cold
so i just added that on that way we
could autumn we could call things if we
want i'll also save on
some of the rendering efficiency stuff
too so
kind of a thing that should have been
added so there's probably going to be a
lot of these little
features that i had that are just part
of opengl that i don't really have the
ability to toggle on and off and that's
just because they're not being
used in any of the functionality but as
they become necessary
i'm going to add little functions to
toggle them on and off
and just one more comment on this whole
adding opengl functionality like
obviously this uses opengl right now but
i intend on
supporting directx and vulcan in the
future
so part of this is yeah i'm adding
functions that literally just call
another function and the point of that
is
you know usually people will say like
don't do that
just use the function that it's calling
and
skip the abstraction but the reason we
want to abstract here is because
we want to support other renderers in
the future so if i just have a
function that toggles call face i don't
have to rewrite that
function in the future i just have it
called the proper function for whatever
for directx vulcan
and that way the function's already
there and ready
and once i add in different rendering
support i'll just add a switch statement
or something for this and it'll just
work
so there's gonna be a lot of that kind
of thing going on and it's a lot of what
i meant by the organization
too earlier all right let's talk about
the dark
launch i just like saying dark launch it
just it just sounds
whatever it's just basically stuff
that's not ready um
usually it's not in the public header
yet but it's like in the back engine or
links
and it's just stuff that's like
preparation for
future because i'm trying to do these
releases on a time-based
thing so like every week or two weeks or
maybe a month at the most i'm gonna
release a new version no matter where
it's at
and some of the stuff just is gonna be
like in there but not quite ready
so that's kind of the dark launch area
is stuff that's in there but not ready
it's just uh you know in an ideal wor
world i would never put anything here
because once i add stuff it would be
ready but
if you're like forcing releases on a
time based scale you're going to have
things that you were like working on
they didn't get done and that's kind of
this area
so basically i started adding some more
mesh uploader stuff
this is just stuff to push stuff to your
graphics card or delete it when you're
done
and previously it was all about
importing models like fbx's
objs stuff like that but i started
adding in just some basic
like raw geometry internally that way
you could like block out levels without
having to start designing stuff in
blender
or i just found it kind of annoying to
be like i need a cube
i guess i've got to go to blender make a
cube and export it you know that sort of
thing
i was just like all right i don't really
would have to do that if i just want a
cube
can i just like add a cube it's you know
it's it's not that
much data i shouldn't have to bring in a
whole model file for it
so that's the whole point of that we're
going to start adding in all this basic
geometry
and that'll make it a lot easier to
block out levels or whatever you're
designing or if it's a building or
whatever
and i also started adding some texture
stuff
for that so the point of this is like
going forward
we're going to be able to like texture
all this raw basic geometry so you might
have a wall it starts out
gray or white or whatever but later you
might want to like put a texture on it
and that's basically the point of this
little method
previously it was just like all built
into the model
up or model uh importer so as you import
a model if it had textures it would
automatically do the things with the
textures
but now it's still going to do that but
also
it's going to let you manually change
textures
to obviously not ready yet but just
something i was like getting
ready alright other changes i added the
mit license
i have no idea
one of my pet peeves is reading legal
stuff it's so boring it's so
dry and it's always just like
it always just has i don't know i don't
even know how to
express this right but just like legal
jargon
and like it just feels like a big time
waster so i don't care about licenses
but obviously i need
something otherwise someone's just going
to steal all this code and claim it for
itself or whatever
because i don't know because there's
evil people in the world they're rare
but they exist
luckily everyone's been super cool
especially on youtube which
has kind of surprised me all right
another changes uh refactor the skybox
made it a little more efficient
basically i started as i started adding
this geometry i realized that like my
skybox was just using a cube
so i was like okay well as i'm adding
this cube geometry
why not just make the skybox use the
same one
and it'll be more efficient and
add remove plane yeah that was just like
a test of the geometry it's really
actually this is not even ready but it's
in there and you can
add remove planes that will
it still needs a lot of work it's not
it's not really
that great yet so yeah that's that's
version four that's everything
and if you're still hanging around we'll
look at some of the code here
i guess i could just do it in like this
way
where i can literally go through the
changes
and what what happened so
this was version three that's old
okay so here's the new stuff i guess
another thing i
i do that i'm actually not real fond of
i'd like to change in the future is
all this debug print so if you're in
debug mode
there's a lot the console becomes a lot
more verbose
and i don't know it might be better to
have a logger or something
but i don't know it's
it's more abstractions to make i'm just
trying to keep it simple i don't really
want to have to mess with that a whole
lot so i just kept a really simple just
using console out
in a perfect world i would probably
implement the boost logger library and
use those functionalities
but like how many more
things do i want to add to this that are
just kind of
not even really part of a game engine
you know
i don't know there's a lot to debate
there but i don't i basically just don't
want to make this library
bigger for things that have nothing to
do with 3ds so like adding loggers and
stuff is
not huge right now but it's probably
going to be something that's going to
have to be done eventually anyway
remove some unused files updated lights
i think this was only in the
example project so there's an example
project i think i changed around some
things there
formatting and light changes so in any
of these you can always like just click
on this and see exactly what was changed
so there's a lot of i think most of this
was just
syntax and formatting i don't think
there was really anything
super big here
yeah uh
and you'll see in here a lot of
formatting and factor
and most of those are kind of boring
changes just like reorganizing and stuff
but hopefully the goal was to never have
to reorganize
the goal is for it to be organized
properly and to not have to reorganize
in between these updates and just you
know add remove functionality and stuff
like that
so the refactor the private core this is
probably the biggest change of this
setting really is just doing this core
and let's see so
yeah all the init and run shut down soft
reset
all this core engine functionality is
basically
set in the core but there's still like
public access to it's kind of weird i'm
not sure if this is the best way to do
it
there's probably some inheritance method
i should use
but yeah i just tried to
abstract it out shrink the size of the
the main
cpp file and put stuff
in there that shouldn't be put stuff in
the core that generally shouldn't be
messed with and
this also can mean like if you're kind
of a new developer and just want to peek
around and maybe make a few changes
the core is probably not the place to
start because it's like
the root functionality that
shouldn't be messed with unless you
really know what you're doing but all
the other stuff it's a little more open
take that with a green salt that's not
necessarily true you might be just fine
going into court messing with stuff if
you're
pretty well studied or you know have a
good understanding of what's going on
so i guess yeah that's the big thing
here's the whole new file
it's pretty large and as you can see so
if you include
core.h you get access to all these
functions that are always built in a cpp
and it's been done through extern but
you can't
just include the core like this only
gets included privately
so there's no public access to this it's
basically the point if you need
if you want public access to this you
have to go
through the ancient archer header
which uh man there's a lot of line
changes
all right i don't know if that's in here
but basically like you can still a knit
the engine
like even though this is fully private
there's a public version of the init
which ends up calling this one
and stuff like that
so yeah there were some changes to uh
how the init works it's mostly the same
but it's no longer a knit engine it's
just
a in it you just don't need everything
that initializes the audio the graphics
your window
basically everything you need all right
so yeah that is definitely by far the
biggest change
uh refactor skybox public input structs
cleanup
oh my some of these changes were stuff
like that i was working on over several
days
and at one point i was finally like okay
this works good where i'm at let's just
clean it up a little bit committed
so yeah obviously i put a lot of time
and work into this
i refactor a lot of the model loader too
it took out this load loader of ours
there were a lot of like unused things
that i missed in
version three or a lot of you know
just a lot of things that were kind of
awkward
that i might have just been testing and
ended up getting changed
all right texture upload support or yeah
we already kind of talked about this but
i'll show you the actual changes here
so basically when you upload a 2d
texture now
it you can now specify whether has alpha
or not
so that is something you need to know as
you go to upload
and it basically just uses the right one
based on your alpha or not
and same for cube maps you can have a
texture you can have alpha or not
cube maps is basically what all the
skybox uses but
cube maps are also nice for other things
too like
if you have a cube that you want to look
like a chest for example
you're going to need different textures
on all six sides of
the square or cube
so yeah uploading cube map textures
is definitely used for the skybox but
it's going to be used for other things
too in the future
so yeah that's that change not super
huge it was probably something i could
have done a long time ago but i just
kind of missed it
changed the sky box so i don't know what
i did here except oh
this is literally a different sky box i
pulled one down there's a
there's a site i found let me see if i
can find it i think it's just this right
here
yeah so this is done in webgl
and you can basically like just get
random different sky boxes and you can
download them it's super awesome
www.tyro dot get help dot io
space 3d pretty nice resource for
for grabbing these and being that this
is in webgl i don't know if anyone has
transferred this anywhere else yet but i
was considering like
messing with this and like
turn it into a c plus projects i think
it's all javascript
i don't know just be something fun to do
to fork it and
make it run within a window it didn't
look like it'd be that hard to do like
all the codes there just needs
translated a little bit but it is
something i could like
add pretty easily or mess with as a side
project
so i basically grabbed one of these sky
boxes and used it
rather than the one i had previously
formatting and light name changes
not exactly sure what this is i think i
was just
updating and revising some of this light
stuff
this looks like it's mostly formatting
but i think i might have fixed a bug
or two restructure to a more game ready
state i don't know what the heck this is
oh this is just the example project
example project so
yeah i started adding in stats i was
going to test test around some game
logic i didn't ever i didn't quite get
to that yet
but this is just like a basic stat block
for
something i plan to test implement here
and it's it gets more into like how you
want to design a game type logic but
obviously you need hit points
mp for magic points energy
focus armor dodge resistance that seemed
like enough to start
plenty and i had i have some theory
written out on some paper about how all
this would like interact
but that's for a later day and probably
for my own little
personal project later
there's the toggle full screen stuff
this was actually
pretty interesting to add so there's the
public header there's access to
the public header and
there's the build of it as you can see
it just calls these core
functions so it's kind of weird because
it's like double abstracted
and i didn't necessarily like this but i
couldn't think of a better way to do it
because the end user still needs access
to it
but i don't want the whole
this whole function built within ancient
archer i wouldn't built within the core
so because this here is a private file
you can only access these functions
through
whatever's available in this header
but like these functions basically if it
calls any functionality from opengl
or jlfw or any other library
if it calls functionality directly from
something else it goes into the core
so i don't want like this ancient
archer.cbp to have
like raw opengl functions and raw
jlfw functions so if they have those
it instead calls core which calls all
that stuff because
core has glw and opengl headers and all
that
but these ancient archer ones should not
because it's abstracted away so that was
also another point of the core
still working on that but i think it
makes a little more sense and it's a
little cleaner to work on
already it did it did cut down like a
thousand lines of code
from this file this file is just getting
huge
yeah so when you toggle full screen well
this is kind of just temporary for now
but basically
it just keeps track of whether or not
you're currently full screen and
flips it as you toggle it
pretty straightforward but ultimately
this ends up calling the
core set full screen because that's a
glw thing
all right what else we got yeah here
they are all
are so if you okay so here's the
function and you can set it to true or
false so set window full screen true or
false
set it to true uh it does this but first
we need to get like
stuff about the windowing mode primary
monitor
so it does operate off your primary
monitor i haven't added in
or abstracted out the support for
multiple monitors yet i don't know if
i'm going to
i don't feel like that's super necessary
in the game usually you're just working
off one window and you full screen your
window that you're playing the game on
i don't intend on supporting more than
one monitor but
i could there's no reason i couldn't
it just seems like a lot of work for
something that nobody will ever use
yeah i think this is fine i actually
change this later there's more changes
to this later because i think i fixed it
up a little more like this don't care
this is the refresh rate
but you want to match the refresh rate
of your monitor so actually i think this
is
change to mode and refresh rate when you
go to full screen and this ones don't
care
because if you set it to your refresh
rate it toggles much quicker
and if you have a really high refresh
rate monitor
you can get those super high frame rates
as everybody wants
all right and if you toggle it off it
just okay so this was a little tricky a
little formula here to get to the middle
of the screen
when you toggle it off it basically puts
your window back to the default size in
the middle of the screen
i considered like saving your last
window with
last window height and then flipping it
back to what you last had
at but it was getting complicated and it
was just
more and more lines of code were getting
added and i was like look i'm just going
to set it back to the default when they
on full screen
and you can resize from there however
you want so it's not that big of a deal
it's like full screen or windowed you
choose
this function should allow that all of
course
just you know windows
change functions that are built into
windows windows 10
or linux or whatever you're using will
work fine when you're not windowed so if
you want to maximize it it all works but
there's no way to full screen
with windows you literally have to have
some kind of function
to do this whole thing here
yeah i think that's about it on here
there's maybe some other little
fixes and stuff and formatting but
okay yeah so from this one i noticed
once i started testing it that there was
this bug
where if you had the screen maximized
and went to full screen and then turned
off full screen
the window would still be considered
maximized
but it would not be maximized so i think
there's a
maybe a little glitch in glfw on that
that they might be able to fix but
it's not that big of a deal i basically
put it i do
i mean let's see
i basically keep track of whether it was
maximized or not if it was maximized
then we call this restore window
and that basically fixes that little
maximize bug
and there's the mode refresh rate
that way it uh can match the hurts of
your
monitor fixed warning
internalized core shaders i talked about
that again i'll show
you that real quick though raw shader
file added
these are huge diffs uh deleted the
gsl files because they're now
all within this course or raw shader
and as you can see these are just con
strings and they're raw literals
it's still you know one of the annoying
limitations of putting them in c files
is was you
had to put the slash new line at the end
of these but if you use this raw
string then you don't have to do that
and it makes them very easy to edit
within a header
so yeah
that alleviated a lot of the pain of
editing editing them within a shader
um i think this nothing big there's
license
i think this is just an example project
i think i wasn't
so the timed out keyboard functionality
you're supposed to return true
if you hit a key that requires a timeout
like an unspammable key and i think i
wasn't returning
one or two functions where i had it set
call face option added
this is simple opengl stuff it's
basically
you can set it set true or false
if you set true turns it on set false it
turns it off
just abstract it out so like i was
saying earlier
later once we have other
renders available we can add some logic
to this to say
hey use the right one basically
set texture method so previously this
was all
done within functions and now this being
abstracted out is going to make it
easier for designing
functions in the future because
there's a bunch of texture banks and you
want to activate them and bind them
before you draw
so this just does it all in one you just
tell which one and then you give it the
texture id
and it just does it
not a huge deal a little abstraction
new upload mesh method for basic
geometry uh yeah i was working on these
these aren't exactly done
but refactor original render
new render overload for basic geometry
spelled it wrong oh well
remove name shader types yeah
animations aren't in here yet still mess
with those
like i had them working at one point but
it was it was
it was not it was not good there were
some issues so
i'm just gonna push that back but
eventually we will get
animations going in here
uh basic plane okay that's it that's
pretty much it
there's the plane methods we can look at
those real quick
so it's in the the header
so you can use it publicly i don't know
if this should be public yet it's not
really
quite properly functional i was just
testing it
basically when you add one you tell
whether it's lit or not which actually
doesn't really matter right now because
there's no normals on this plane i need
to add normals to it still
so if it's lit it uses a lit shader
otherwise
diff shader make sure they're set up of
course because we need to do that
and we just have a big list of planes
that we draw if they're added
and we do have an option to remove those
which i added to
see i'm trying to find the code so yeah
it just stores a vector of planes for
now
and yeah this render function
i always i've worked on this render
function a lot
there's it's always been changed and
adjusted
i noticed there were some glitches
i don't remember what they were exactly
but basically the way i was
reasoning about this updating the
shaders
something was a little weird with it i
think i oh yeah
if your camera was empty i needed to
make sure the view matrix was set
but uh i don't think i want to support
empty cameras
at least not in that way i mean empty
cameras fine but like
what should you get if you don't add a
camera you know if you just try to run
the engine without adding a camera so i
had to think about that and basically
what i want to do is leave it default
but i don't know still kind of
considering default being
your position or your view position is
you know zero zero zero
if you don't add a camera and you're
looking down the z
axis but then you need to think about
things like
okay so is it going to be perspective or
is it going to be
orthographic i haven't really considered
all that yet
because mainly this engine is for 3d it
has pretty limited 2d support
you uh yeah it does have pretty limited
2d support it's really intended for 3d
but it wouldn't be that hard for me to
add some 2d support i just have to
think about how i'm doing these cameras
a little bit
i think i had it all in there at one
point i took it out because it wasn't
working
as i intended so that seems to happen a
lot
all right and there's the whole plane
drawer thing
uh plane has its own draw method so that
it just handles it but you do need to
set
the view matrix and it just does it from
the front camera this is really a hack
this is like really
a bad set of code because what if
there's no front camera it's just going
to try to do it and
throw an error basically and it's going
to say like
null reference or something like that
because camera is going to be empty
and there's no front view matrix
but so yeah the basically the engine
assumes you add
one main camera but it's not really
explicit so that's something i need to
change in upcoming versions
is just how this whole camera thing
works and
whether you really need one or not
because what if you never intend to move
and you just want to work with your
screen space
i haven't fully reasoned that out it's
basically intending
intended that you have one camera and
that's in perspective
and that's just kind of how it's made to
work right now
so we'll see going forward also
one day when this is like more usable
and people start building stuff with it
it's going to be a lot it's going to
make a lot more sense
for earth i'm trying to think of what
the right way to board this but
basically it's going to be a lot easier
for me to figure out what features i
need to
make sure i support and what people are
trying to use and
because right now it's just like me
goofing around and whatever i feel like
needs changed or added that's what i do
there's i don't think there's anyone
else who uses this right now
there's just a lot better game engines
obviously you know i'm
i'm just doing this one from scratch so
it is purely
a learning experiment and experience so
that's the point of it really so if
you're
wanting to get into gaming just no idea
where to start this would probably be a
good place to like
just play around and kind of figure out
some basics it's
it's a conglomeration of many tutorials
and many
lessons learned all just being coded up
all right i think that's all the main
stuff for this one there
is the what is this load plane
there's some basic
upload a plane so uh yeah these
you're gonna see like load plane load
cube load whatever
and it's just some really basic geometry
with some indices
and i need i do need to put normals and
stuff in here too but it's not
like that yet so that'll be later
but also the point of this is anytime
you need a plane
you have the geometry available you just
call
load plane and grab this return value
and it is
the vao to the plane
because it only sets once if you call it
again it's just going to return the one
that's already loaded
that way you don't reload the same
geometry over and over you can just
reuse this as you need
yeah i guess that's basically it and
support to remove the plane in case
you're no longer using it
just goes off the uid so these planes
have a unique id
i don't know if i talked about this
before but there's like a little unique
id system
so any like model or
geometry or anything when you add it to
the
when you add it to like your world it's
given a unique id
and if you want to look it up or if you
want to remove it or if you want to
access it or change it
a lot of times you have to access it by
its unique id
and it's sort of just a hacky thing that
i did to
be able to keep track of stuff and add
and remove stuff without
like getting completely lost
there's a lot more to talk about that
it's a very it's a very
simple system when you when you get down
to it there's not a whole lot to it
other than things get unique ids and
anything that has unique id often has
functions that require you like if you
want to remove a plane
this is going to check the the vector of
planes
but also it's like which one it could
as your game goes on and things change
its spot within the vector could change
like it could
start out second element but later
become the first element
so you can't necessarily just say it's
uh
element one or two or three in the
vector because it might it might move
so rather than that they just have
unique ids and you say hey
the plane with this unique id do
something with it in this case it's a
remove
but like with the props they use unique
ids too and they're used for like moving
them around
it's not super efficient but it doesn't
seem to matter yet because i haven't
built any big
scale things where it matters it's it's
plenty fast enough for what it is
uh what else we got here oh yeah this is
just testing the plane
all right so let's run the engine
okay so here it is i'm gonna put in
release mode so
it builds a little faster and this is
running
the example project here
which i've somewhat refactored and
yeah it's going to change every update
but basically it's just
something to to test with
and just make sure everything's working
so you can see the new sky box here
it's more of a might be really hard to
see on youtube but basically
my screen is really bright so it's not
too bad for me to see it just one of the
skies from that thing and here's our
classic peasant man still
spinning we've got a little bit of light
from a directional light that's supposed
to sort of emulate that
moon sun thing or whatever it is but
there's also a flashlight you can toggle
with f
and the lighting should work a lot
better now i still got
i still have to do some work on the
model loading light because i don't
think
all the specular and normal textures
work right now
but it looks half decent with spotlights
and stuff
you can get away with it there's also no
shadows so
uh not the best here's our plane just i
just tested adding it so
and if we go below it and look up you'll
see that it's gone and that's because
the back face calling
so that seems to work i added the
calling on that it so you can't see it
at all
if you're below it but going above it
where it is there it is
all right and i added a hotkey to remove
it and add it back
just testing it out there and remove
works fine
so we could in theory you know have
remove anything on the fly that's one of
the points of this
all the stuff that you see within the
scene can be like
changed on the fly that's the point of
it being a game because when you're in a
game like you're going to different
levels and stuff and
it needs to support that and it does i
didn't mess with the audio at all but
all the audio works
fine so i don't think there's any audio
in this scene right now
all right in full screen toggle that
looks like it takes a while to show up
on obs but yeah
toggling full screen works pretty good
toggle back off goes to the center
um still got the little inventory thing
going on i'll guess there's sound with
that
so as you can see that hover i didn't
change anything with that so obviously
it works
but another thing this does is i put
some logic in here
to make the mouse stop moving around
your camera
when you open your inventory because uh
that you need to be able to click and
stuff and
whatever you want to do you know all
right
well i think that's about it
new month new version
all right well appreciate you guys
thanks for watching let me know what you
think below
all the stuff about the bounties does
still apply for now i just haven't
changed that
it's under projects here i know a few
people like forked it and we're messing
with a little bit but
yeah i think did i did i had any other
stuff myself
haven't cut the shadow mapping i haven't
got the hdr skies i think i know how to
do this though i might do this for the
next version
um sound effect distance tuning
i didn't mess with that musically but
haven't missed that yeah i haven't
messed with like any of the stuff water
bodies
i think this is going to be part of
i don't know i have some ideas for how
to add this but basically
you could make a texture that goes along
with like the planes or
squares and you could like custom water
bodies and stuff but
i don't know it's not in there at all
yet i have some ideas to to make some
hacky
water bodies that would look maybe have
these
3d model animations yeah that so yeah i
literally haven't messed with any of
these
feature bounty stuff but getting to the
point where i kind of know how to do
some of these well some of them i
definitely know how to do like i know i
already know how to do the sound just
tuning i'm pretty sure i know how to fix
this looping issue
just haven't done it just been working
on other things
so yeah i have some pretty decent ideas
about how to approach all of these
but if you get to it first and you make
a pull request i will
and it works accept pull request i will
send you whatever this bounty is
it's not a whole lot but hey if it's
easy for you know how to do it
it's like easy money you know and you
get some practice and some good have
points and all that
so at some point if these sit for a long
time or there's some that i just can't
figure out i'll probably
increase the bounty if no one's done it
at that point all right
appreciate you guys and is there
anything else
oh yeah as i said like the beginning of
this video
this project is my own personal project
it's not a part of code tech tutorials
this is the library i like talking about
and i think there's a lot to learn from
it
so if you want to sponsor this project
you can
it just goes to my personal patreon or
coffee i'm not sure about these yet i
don't i haven't really
pushed these at all but this is just
like a product
basically the whole point is this is my
own personal project
if you want to support it it's actually
kind of separate from the channel
because like i don't know say in 10
years if
i get banned from youtube or something
it's gonna have nothing to do with this
project
so a little separation there like i
started this project before i started
youtube
so there's that too all right
well yeah that's all i can think about
to talk about right now
let me know what you guys think peace
[Music]
out
[Music]
you